where are the people only see old tires
Ola media a nice pots potential beauty
she goes around to businesses in Lagos
collecting tires that are no longer fit
for vehicles Ola media is a computer
engineering graduate but she has found
her calling making decorative furniture
dogs make use of every tires we see not
hospitals are saved to the used way
through the aisles coming out or used to
the tires broken we can't use them back
in her studio the creative work begins
step by step an old tire becomes a
beautiful Ottoman and the environment is
being protected - in Nigeria sustainable
living is quite new and the good thing
is the vision the acceptance is ok is
welcoming people are really wowed they
love what to see but we want to I like
to tell people - everyone needs to to be
an environmental advocates olam ET
celles her pieces for as much as 20,000
naira that's about fifty five US dollars
she even has orders from Europe but are
there any concerns about health issues
we go by the tires we do like to
different areas of covering while we are
making them so your tires your auto
miles are not gonna admit any poisonous
gases to you or to the environment
sometimes people bring their old tires
to her and get a 30 to 50 percent
discount of her products instead of you
tore your tires in the gutter in your
drainage you can keep them you can call
us we put them home and
to talk about the price Steve an old
motorcycle tires get a beautiful rap
recently Ola MIDI has started training
other people who are concerned about the
impact of tile a ston the environment
Ola Metis products are now showcased in
some of the major furniture stores in
Lagos